[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de francés 24
tenemos 22 historias que contar dos
hombres poderosos se enfrentan a
denuncias de abuso y violación en mexico
una decena de mujeres alzaron su voz en
casos separados contra el político félix
salgado candidato a gobernador por el
partido morena y contra el diplomático y
filántropo andrés roemer justamente hoy
vamos a escuchar dos voces que denuncian
pero antes aquí está el resumen de los
casos
la fiscalía general de ciudad de méxico
abrió una investigación contra andrés
roemer por abuso sexual contra la
bailarina it's el sanas quien denunció
que en 2019 fue violentada en una
supuesta reunión de trabajo empezó
mis piernas
masajear mis piernas se cumple
al tocarse el caso contra el escritor
diplomático y presentador mexicano
podría ser apenas la punta del iceberg
tres mujeres se identificaron para
señalar a roemer de abusador y violador
y al menos otras seis contaron sus
historias que ahora circulan por las
redes
rmr publicó un vídeo para defenderse me
presento con ustedes soy andrés roemer y
estoy aquí para dar la cara andrés
roemer habría traído a sus víctimas a su
sótano y habría repetido amenazas en su
posición de poder así lo dice la
periodista montserrat ortiz otra de las
denunciantes tome un cojín que había en
la sala y me cubrí las piernas pero él
me lo quitó y me comenzó a tocar le dije
que no lo empuje le dije que quería irme
pero no se detuvo este caso se suma en
la escena pública a las denuncias contra
félix salgado macedonio senador político
de morena cercano al presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador y quien en junio
buscará ser gobernador del estado de
guerrero
salgado macedonio fue acusado de
violación por dos mujeres una de ellas
dice que fue violentada en el año 91
cuando era menor de edad la segunda
demanda data de 2017 y es de una ex
trabajadora
el diario la jornada de guerrero donde
salgado ejercido como director sobre el
también pesan señalamientos de abuso lo
que ha desatado pedidos para que sea
investigado y su candidatura retiradas
incluso el partido movimiento ciudadano
solicitó en el congreso un juicio
político pero macedonio se excusa en la
inexistencia de pruebas y el presidente
mantiene su respaldo diciendo que se
trata de un linchamiento político y que
será candidato a menos que se demuestre
que es culpable
están con nosotros desde ciudad de
méxico con cerrado ortiz periodista en
reporte en vivo y también está con
nosotros patricia olamendi abogada de
basilia castañeda una de las
denunciantes de félix salgado defensora
de derechos humanos e integrante de la
ong nosotras tenemos otros datos
bienvenidas a ellas hoy
muchas gracias montserrat voy a comenzar
con usted para escuchar su testimonio y
luego vamos a darle el micrófono a
patricia entonces comienzo preguntándole
usted sumó su voz después de la denuncia
de ese le dé chance contra andrés roemer
quién es este hombre cuántas denuncias
hay contra él
hasta el día de ayer las autoridades acá
en la ciudad de méxico confirmaron
cuatro denuncias
100 formales ante la fiscalía de la
ciudad de mexico sin embargo vemos
alrededor de otras 10 12 mujeres que
estamos a punto de acercarnos a las
autoridades para iniciar nuestras
propias denuncias legales
en quién es este hombre me preguntabas
es una persona muy poderosa es el
director el cofundador de la ciudad de
las ideas uno de los festivales más
importantes por ejemplo para la ciudad
de puebla tiene su programa en adn 40 de
tvazteca que es una de las televisoras
más poderosas de este país y también con
mucho peso en varios países
latinoamericanos afortunadamente o bueno
de una forma que no esperábamos las
víctimas las las denunciantes la la
universidad de columbia en la unesco le
quitaron hace poco tiempo el apoyo que
tenía también por parte de ellos
entonces fíjate las instituciones
internacionales tardaron menos en
pronunciarse en contra de este señor que
el propio méxico
no quiero retomar demasiado su historia
porque ustedes ya la ha difundido
suficiente en las redes sociales y no
queremos volver a los momentos de dolor
es sin embargo una mujer que es víctima
de abuso o de violación se paraliza
instintivamente esa mujer no se mueve
porque fisiológicamente su cuerpo asume
que no luchar es la única manera de
sobrevivir o incluso de morir sin dolor
los abusos son de los crímenes más
atroces que existen y en su testimonio
que usted publicó hace algunos días
confesó que solamente hasta que vivió la
experiencia entendió lo que es realmente
sentirse paralizada y reconoció que
inicialmente pensó que todo esto era su
responsabilidad pero no y entender esas
cosas son trascendentales para sanar y
para reclamar justicia que nos puede
decir
claro eso tanto y periodista yo la mayor
parte de mi carrera le dedicado a
denunciar violencia de género y
feminicidios crímenes sexuales y yo no
entendía justo a las mujeres que yo les
preguntaba por qué no denuncias en algún
momento llegué a decirles denuncia por
favor necesitas ir con las autoridades y
ellas no querían yo cuando vivo esto es
cuando entiendo por qué esas mujeres no
quisieron ir a denunciar porque sentían
culpa porque sentían miedo pues todo lo
que yo sentí también en este momento y
por eso no denuncie hace cuatro años
y creo que es muy importante también
entender que cada una tenemos nuestro
propio proceso es decir yo me tardé
cuatro hits él se tardó dos habrá quien
se ha tardado hasta diez años te lo
puedo asegurar de las víctimas que
estamos platicando en este momento sobre
el caso entonces algo también importante
es dejar bien claro que un abuso no es
nuestra culpa yo en un momento llegué a
pensar que si lo era entonces es
importante estar conscientes que somos
víctimas no nada más de un sujeto sino
de todo un sistema aquí en méxico
también somos víctimas de la impunidad
de las autoridades pero en última
instancia va a ser nuestra culpa nunca
va a ser nuestra culpa ser víctimas de
un hombre y de un sistema y de un
sistema político negligente e impune
y que no protege a las mujeres voy a
hacer una pausa con usted montserrat
para abrir el micrófono para patricia y
retomo en su calidad de abogada de una
de las denunciantes de félix salgado
cuéntenos por favor en qué va el caso
bueno yo creo que es muy importante que
el público sepa quién es la persona
acusada de agresiones sexuales el poder
político en méxico es muy fuerte igual
que el poder económico y en este caso
hablamos de un hombre que ha pasado en
varios partidos políticos que ha sido
desde los finales de los 90 se ha
contado con fuero porque ha sido
legislador federal senador presidente
municipal y el fuero lamentablemente en
méxico se utiliza con un mecanismo de
protección porque tiene que pasar un
juicio dentro del congreso para que
estas personas puedan ser enjuiciadas
por un delito
el caso de la persona que estamos
representando en 9 abogadas feministas y
quiero aclararlo es un trabajo que
estamos haciendo en apoyo a las mujeres
que pone en evidencia un el continuo de
violencia que existe y la impunidad ella
fue violada y así lo afirma y así lo ha
testificado ante su propio partido el
partido morena por este hombre cuando
ella tenía 17 años de edad si bien
intentó denunciar en ese momento él era
senador de la república y también
candidato a la gubernatura igual que
ahorita lo intentó en diferentes
ocasiones se fueron a otro partido
político y estaban en el perredé pasaron
al partido morena son fundadores del
partido morena y ella trató a lo largo
de estos años de tren de tener apoyo no
fácil porque no lo dijo por mucho tiempo
obviamente el nivel de afectación de
ella es serio es severo pero finalmente
rompe el silencio cuando se da cuenta
que él puede ganar las elecciones siendo
el candidato de su partido lo denuncia
en su partido te rinde su testimonio en
su partido y aparte ella cuenta con una
denuncia penal que finalmente después de
mucho esfuerzo la logró presentar y al
igual que ella hay otras mujeres que han
presentado denuncias penales en
diferentes momentos y cada vez se suman
más testimonios de mujeres que han sido
acusadas abusadas y hostigada
sexualmente por esta persona actualmente
el procedimiento penal está en las
fiscalías una nota muy importante el
presidente ha dicho que quiere que
esto lo resuelve la justicia si él sigue
teniendo fueron como lo has tenido todos
estos años es casi imposible que la
justicia lo pueda resolver en el partido
su denuncia está presentada ya rindió su
testimonio y bueno la consecuencia si el
partido lo encuentra responsable es que
se le quite la candidatura y sobre todo
que se pueda generar tal vez un proceso
como el que se está haciendo para que
pueda estar tener el juicio político y
por lo tanto poderse continuar los
trámites legales para que este hombre
pueda salir adelante en méxico es un
dato muy importante 4 de cada 10 mujeres
según una encuesta se calcula que sufren
violencia sexual pero sólo 8 mujeres de
100 denuncian porque el nivel de
impunidad es altísimo ni siquiera pasas
de las fiscalías o de las cargas de
policía ahí la voy a interrumpir un
segundo patricia quiero hablar más de
eso es que el camino siempre
es duro para una demanda por violación
los sistemas de justicia no están a
favor de las mujeres y es muy común
encontrar trabas más aún se aumentan las
barreras cuando es precisamente desde la
propia presidencia de lópez obrador
desde donde se apoya a un hombre que
está en proceso de investigación y ya
para el cierre de este testimonio de
esta voz que usted nos presta hoy para
ellos hoy porque sería gravísimo que un
hombre investigado por violación sea
gobernador nosotros les hemos dicho y
quiero decirte que muchísimas mujeres
miles
yo creo que millones nos vamos a
manifestar de alguna manera el 8 de
marzo le hemos dicho que poner a este
hombre en el poder es legitimar la
violencia contra las mujeres es
olvidarnos de todo lo que hemos logrado
en leyes en trámites en procedimientos y
dejar un violador es como ponernos una
estocada en el corazón
muchas gracias a patricia olamendi y
muchas gracias a monserrat do ortiz a
ambas por sus testimonios con mucha
valentía para hablar frente a las
cámaras de estos temas y en ellas hoy
simplemente seguimos atentas y esperando
que la investigación siga su curso y
sobre todo que se haga justicia la mujer
no se viola la mujer no se toca la mujer
no se mata siga con nosotros nos vemos
próximamente en france24
[Música]